what I loved a trip again yeah yeah do
you think you could do it and you know
maybe it's just like you just don't
maybe it's getting [ __ ] up that's the
bad thing like just getting [ __ ] up
just getting drunk and coked up and
maybe that's the problem maybe no no
it's kind of shamanic ceremony maybe it
wouldn't be a problem at all well here's
the deal it's all one thing getting
[ __ ] up shamanic whatever if you're
taking drugs and you [ __ ] up you're
[ __ ] up doesn't matter if it's
shamanic or not if you if you get high
and that's net tweaks that little thing
in my brain that goes um here I go
remember in your brain I got high for 30
years right
I'm from the sixties right with the best
of them I got right and it took them
down some of them most of them you came
through it remarkably unscathed if you
think about it yeah thank you God it's
pretty amazing thank you God thank you
God
mmm think about that one yeah think
about that we could talk for two hours
about times I did [ __ ] and almost died
so sure you know and then I could also
tell you how many times I took [ __ ] and
wrote things like you know I'm listening
to this guitar lick the Joe's playing he
did an interview here with you yeah but
he didn't tell you how in his [ __ ]
sleep he would play these riffs and I
come down the hallway because you know
as I see it of course not as they see it
but as I see it we were up in New
England and he was playing at a place
and I mowed the lawn my mind my parents
place and I quit my last band and I was
[ __ ] allah who saw her I was crying I
was in no more bands the dream was over
he drives up in an mg we go and he's
playing that night I swear to god this
happened and so we decided to move down
to Boston but all in an apartment
because I thought I knew why those bands
didn't make it but I knew in my heart
did if I had a bro in a band like I'm
making a Keith like the kinks
David David you know ray any of those
bands they have that you have
there was two guys that were really
tight that feed off each other they fed
off each other exactly so we moved down
there I got really tight with Joe I hear
him
he get weak it's so sweat we so stoned
on booze Boone's Farm
you know and we I mean it's [ __ ] her
living there I said what do you say
what'd you say anyway but he would play
these licks that was so [ __ ] for
every song you've ever heard sweet
emotion every one of those licks walked
this way there's 20 that got lost in the
ether right 20 the girls lost ether so I
went out and bought a little thing
called tape recorder back then remember
this was 71 you know a lot of [ __ ]
wasn't no phones no cell phones so I
would record that [ __ ] and so anyway
where we're going with this that's
that's what that's where these songs
came from and stuff would come out of my
head while I was like sweet emotion well
[ __ ] give me paper and pen I write that
[ __ ] down suddenly
whoops on the radio see so I use that
place with you game you go to and you
know edibles give a write some of your
routines on yours yeah well there you go
know for sure well and also check this
out the best part of it is when I got
sober I started writing even even better
[ __ ] I'd go in a room with four guys and
say we're going in the right ahead
we're gonna stay in this [ __ ] room
until we do or until we can't say each
other smell
and we would leave in seven hours with a
[ __ ] song and a good one and one that
would live way past all of us check that
shooter what did it feel like when you
when you did have these drunken stoned
moments when you came up with a song
like sweet emotion or a riff or and then
all of a sudden you're listening to it
on the radio how how [ __ ] surreal is
that what does that like I remember we
used to go up to UM first of all most of
our first stuff was recorded down in
Hell's Kitchen in New York or the record
plant you know John Lennon our studio
upstairs and we were down in Studio A
with Jack Douglas and them so we went
from there for the 70s and then into the
70s mmm
I had done every drug on the planet that
I could because I thought it was cool
and if I didn't I wouldn't be cool
and those were the kind of people I hung
out with you can't do that dude you
ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] man so and you get
early 80s totally fubar 84 85 86 what
was eighties coke uh a lot of the hard
stuff yeah 70s or 60s and 70s was 60s
was weed right drinkin getting jiggy
with the foot you know with the stuff
that was happening with the English
invasion